[Musik]
wir sind in quito einer kleinen
provinzhauptstadt zu dem nordwesten
kolumbiens
mittendrin das büro vom internationalen
komitee vom roten kreuz
der delegierte abraham tobago bricht zu
einer sechstägigen mission auf das
satellitentelefon haben wir wofür sagen
wie es
da in die tasche
alles ist wichtig wir kommen nicht
zurück wir können die reise nicht
unterbrechen aber das wichtigste ist das
satellitentelefon
wenn wir keinen empfang haben können wir
wenigstens das hauptquartier in bogota
erreichen
mit dem sind wir immer in kontakt aber
bogotá ist weit weg und ein feld trip
ist in dieser gegend der welt ein
unterfangen mit vielen unbekannten und
risiken
das sehen sie heute
abra hamburger trifft verzweifelte kampf
- der krieg zwischen regierung rebellen
und drogenbaronen hat ihnen alles
genommen
ihk-präsident peter maurer besucht eines
der schlimmsten gefängnisse afrikas
[Musik]
newcomerin stephanie erprobt in genf den
ernstfall im feld
[Musik]
in afghanistan setzt sich nadine dafür
ein dass menschen ohne arme und beine
nicht ausgestoßen werden
[Musik]
gleich hinter guido beginnt der
dschungel
hier herrschen eigene gesetze kriminelle
gruppen sogenannte ban dass kriminelles
und rebellen haben das sagen
abraham hat sie und das militär über
seine mission informiert das dient der
sicherheit genau wie das waffenverbot
und das emblem
wenn wir in abgelegenen gebieten sind in
denen wir mit bewaffneten gruppen
rechnen müssen ist es sehr wichtig und
identifizierbar zu sein
so können sie uns wenigstens aus
angemessener distanz erkennen
seit 50 jahren kommt diese gegend der
provinz chocó nicht zur ruhe
und wie überall leidet auch hier die
zivilbevölkerung am meisten denn immer
wieder kommt es zu
einschüchterungsversuchen entführungen
und mord die letzte gräueltat liegt nur
tage zurück
[Musik]
kannst du dir vorstellen in einem dorf
zu leben in dem jemand den du von klein
auf kennt mit einer axt getötet wird
das passiert hier immer wieder gerade
vor einer woche in dem dorf an dem ihr
vorbeigefahren sind rebellen und
bewaffnete gruppen schaffen ein klima
der angst und des misstrauens
das spüren wir auch in diesem dorf
dessen namen wir nicht nennen um die
einwohner zu schützen
etwas über 100 menschen leben hier
die hygiene ist mangelhaft das nächste
spital weit weg die menschen sind
genügsam weil das dorf sehr abgelegen
und die gegend gefährlich ist findet
kein anderes hilfswerk hierher das ikk
unterstützt die bewohner mit reisfeldern
kongo gehts aber haben die planer und
sein team haben auch den bau dieses
gemeindehauses finanziert wir sind in
diesem dorf weil hier bewaffnete
gruppierungen ihr unwesen treiben
natürlich in deren anwesenheit ist es
schwierig freizusprechen und fremden zu
vertrauen
die projekte sind ein zusätzlicher
vector und der bevölkerung besser helfen
zu können und vertrauen aufzubauen
die bauern haben illegal kuka pflanzen
angebaut aus denen drogen hergestellt
werden können weil sich viele
rebellengruppen mit drogengeschäften
finanzieren griff die regierung durch
und besprühte die felder mit gift
unser tägliches brot besteht aus bananen
reis mais man york mit dem wir unsere
kinder ernähren
wer wird uns nun in zukunft helfen die
hunger in neuler zu stopfen
kuka hat uns nicht viel gebracht aber
wenigstens konnten wir damit überleben
aber wenn die regierung unsere felder
besprüht wie könnt ihr uns dann helfen
eine schwierige frage für abraham tobago
und sein team
[Musik]
wir sind in einem fiktiven land namens
i'll be seen
hier treibt diese kooperation front slf
ihr unwesen ist der fun i l l absolviert
in genf den ausbildungskurs zur
delegierten heute muss sich die
28-jährige aus lausanne dem rollenspiel
als missionschef in berühmten
bei einem chat und wird das team von den
etf europäischen defense forces
kontrolliert was machen sie hier
haben sie papiere wir sind 7
ich bin g missionsleiter rinn hier sind
meine identitätspapiere ihre ausweise
bitte
das ikrk team hat kurz zuvor ein lager
mit vertriebenen besucht das könnte ihm
jetzt zum verhängnis werden
obwohl stéphanie bewusst ist dass dies
alles nur eine übung ist welcher
nationalität haben sie ich bin von hier
all these
ich bin aus dem iran kolumbianerin
deutscher schweizerin spanier und sie
sagten sie seien die missionschefin und
sie sind deutsche ja du überprüften wir
verhafteten einige deutsche die spione
waren überprüft seine kontakte sein
verhältnis zu asia und was er über die
slf weiß
wir wollen alles wissen was machen sie
hier sind sie ärzte sie haben hier ein
rotes kreuz
wir haben hier eine verwundete können
sie helfen wir haben einen
erste-hilfe-kasten okay ist da jemand
der an meiner soldaten versorgen kann
sie waren im slf gebiet ja das waren wir
was haben sie da gemacht wir haben
abgeklärt ob unbeteiligte zivilisten
hilfe brauchen wie wasser medikamente
sie haben also mit der snf gesprochen
wahnsinn dorthin zu gehen das sind
terroristen die werden sie erschießen
wir haben bei unserer ankunft eine
vereinbarung mit der edf und der slf
getroffen
wir sprechen mit beiden parteien und wir
beziehen keine stellung wir wollen aber
sicherstellen dass wir uns um die
menschen kümmern können die sich nicht
an den kampfhandlungen beteiligen
sie ist verwundet
ich will wissen wo die genau sind das
sind leider informationen die wir nicht
weitergeben dürfen
genauso wie wenn wir von der slf
aufgehalten werden dürfen wir eure
position nicht weitergeben
das ist zu ihrer sicherheit und der
sicherheit von uns allen was könnt ihr
für sie tun
ihre kollegin sagt sie sei auf eine lang
mine getreten
es geht ihr schlecht sie sollte dringend
in ein spital
mich können sie tun wenn sie unbewaffnet
ist können wir sie mitnehmen und sie so
schnell als möglich ins nächste spital
bringen
was passiert mit meinem kollegen hier
er muss überprüft werden darf ich fragen
wie genau er überprüft werden soll
er wird verdächtigt ein spion zu sein
wir wollen wissen mit wem er kontakt hat
er sagte bereits dass ihr in kontakt mit
der sl website wir brauchen zeit um das
zu überprüfen
dann müssen wir bei ihm bleiben wir
können nicht jemanden vom team allein
zurücklassen
sie können nicht
es werde noch immer gekämpft wir
behalten ihn hier jemand von der
militärpolizei berlin abholen wir können
sie auf dem laufenden halten
kommandant kommandant er ist deutscher
er sagt er habe mit den terroristen
gesprochen
[Musik]
zurück im dorf dessen ernte vernichtet
wurde
ein bauer lädt uns zu sich nach hause
er will abraham doblo zeigen welche
auswirkungen die besprühung der felder
auf ihre tägliche nahrung hat schön
haben sie es hier ist das wohnzimmer
senior da hinten ist die küche wer
schläft hier
hier schläft ein sohn also in der
hängematte
nein die star wenn man müde ist und wo
schläft das kind der sohn er nein das
ist der neffe hier schläft also der sohn
und was gibts dort können wir das zimmer
sehen ja gehen sie rein
nach ihn wenn sie gestatten die eltern
sehr gut
die gestamp wie heißt du und die
toiletten dort beim wasserrohr wo
draußen draußen
und wenn es regnet tropft es weiß ja
wenn es regnet steht alles hier unter
wasser
das ist die qualität nach dem besprühen
[Musik]
die bewohner essen ein neues bisweilen
trotzdem obwohl das gift krank macht der
hunger lässt ihnen keine wahl
abraham ahnt dass seine möglichkeiten
beschränkt sind
wir sind keine utopisten wir arbeiten in
der realität mit dem konflikt aber wir
glauben wenigstens dass es etwas besser
wird dass das leid ein wenig kleiner
wird und es ein wenig vorwärts geht
am nächsten morgen wollen abraham und
sein team den schaden in den feldern mit
eigenen augen begutachten
[Musik]
wir sind in der 9 millionen metropole
kinshasa der kongolesischen hauptstadt
dakar präsident peter maurer ist während
unseren dreharbeiten gerade mal ein jahr
im amt
hier will er seine delegation besuchen
die fünftgrößte maurer ist keiner der
vom büro aus die welt beurteilt lieber
geht er hinaus zu den mitarbeitenden
weltweit immerhin 13.000 sie alle wissen
dass ich wohl der jüngste hier bin
weniger alters wegen als vielmehr
hinsichtlich meiner erfahrung im ikk
ich bin erst seit juli vergangenen
jahres an der spitze des ikk das herz
unseres mandats bleibt die bewaffnete
gewalt und ich denke wenn sich die
konflikte ändern wenn die akteure
wechseln wenn sich die waffen und die
kämpfenden ändern ist es an uns unser
mandat den neuen konflikten anzupassen
ein großes dankeschön für ihr engagement
ich schätze das ende der präsident
versucht sich gar an der hülle des
kongolesischen roten kreuzes
von susi wimmer war
[Musik]
[Applaus]
ihr habt es gehört da muss ich noch ein
wenig üben
das ist schon so gut wie microsoft
mediale immer gespalten inspirierte
sitte konfrontiert mit der schlimmsten
sachen und trauen sich da muss man sich
jeden tag wieder mut mache dabei wichtig
fahrer und nur träumen wenn man die
zukunft ursache fest und und einfach mal
ausprobiert wie das für mich am leben
noch immer in bayern seit lernen fördern
was mit mir so ein normaler menschlicher
kraft hätte die arbeit zu machen
kraft braucht ihr denn die nächste
station ist ein gefängnis das als eines
der schlimmsten in ganz afrika gilt
[Musik]
während der übung im fiktiven albea wird
der teamkollege von stéphanie lr noch
immer festgehalten
sie bemüht sich um dessen freilassung
inzwischen soll die verletzte soldatin
so schnell wie möglich ins spital
gebracht werden
was macht ihr für uns wir werden uns
erst um ihre kollegin kümmern
[Musik]
vorsicht und sie in den wagen
wir sind daher hier wird gekämpft
wir wollen sie so schnell wie möglich
raus bringen sie sagen mir ich soll
oberst parker kontaktieren um die
passier liste zu checken
ich werde das gleich tun das ist ein
guter tipp entschuldigung aber ihr
kommandant darf nicht mit einer waffe in
unserem auto sitzen
ihr kommandant sitzt mit einer waffe im
auto bei der verwundeten das geht auf
keinen fall
das ist einer meiner soldaten
sie bringen sie ins spital es gibt hier
kampfhandlungen und slf die werden sie
anhalten und sie töten
sie haben überhaupt keinen schutz darum
begleitet er sie leider können wir keine
bewaffneten transportieren
das ist absoluter wahnsinn wie wollen
sie sich gegen die slf schützen wir
haben die flagge mit dem roten kreuz und
zu verrückt es klingen mag das ist unser
bester schutz gegen die slf sie wird
sicher und wohlbehalten im spital
ankommen
sie versprechen natalie wohlbehalten den
spital zu fahren da haben sie ihre
papiere steigen sie ein
wir wollen dass sie so schnell als
möglich verschwinden sobald wir unseren
kollegen mitnehmen können
zeigen sie mir nochmals das papier mit
dem namen wir haben schon einige übungen
gemacht aber das spielte ich die rolle
des soldaten
das war viel einfacher als die person zu
spielen die mit dem militär verhandelt
im moment ist es lustig weil man weiss
es gilt nicht ernst steigen sie ein und
verlassen sie so schnell als möglich das
gebiet
die terroristen die terroristen los los
los
[Musik]
wir sind in einer der gefährlichsten
gegenden der welt der jahrzehntelange
krieg hat tiefe spuren hinterlassen
es ist morgen in kabul angestellte und
patienten kommen ins prothesen zentrum
des ikk gebaut wurde es für
kriegsversehrte heute ist es auch offen
für unfallopfer und zivilisten freund
oder feind
hier sind alle gleich
nadine ist direktor des zentrums ein
einheimischer die mehr als 80 prozent
der ikk mitarbeitenden viele patienten
can touch wood ihn persönlich weiß um
ihre geschichten und ihre schicksale zum
beispiel mohammed ehsan
er hat beide hände fallen der 38-jährige
hat es hier besonders schwer denn einer
der nichts für den unterhalt der familie
beisteuern kann wird zur belastung und
nicht selten zum außenseiter
jetzt trainiert ehsan mit seinen
prothesen für das leben draußen für uns
alltägliche handgriffe für ihn ein stück
zurück gewonnene autonomie vor einem
jahr hatte er seine linke hand verloren
und jetzt vor vier fünf monaten seine
rechte nicht wegen eines unfalls sondern
wegen einer krankheit
vorher hat sein sohn alles für ihn
gemacht jetzt mit den prothesen kann er
wie das selber tun
der 22 jährige patient ali mohammad hat
ein bein verloren
er wurde an der grenze zum iran
angeschossen natur dient der hier im
zentrum zum physiotherapeuten
ausgebildet wurde gibt anweisungen
die säfte musst du ein wenig nach vorne
schieben und die prothese musst du
aufrecht halten dann kannst du sie
belasten
[Musik]
denn gesund wie fuß musst du weiter nach
vorne setzen und den künstlichen weniger
mein fuß ist genau gleich wie diner
genau gleich wenn du den künstlichen fuß
auf gesetzt hast musst du erst die hüfte
nach vorne bringen und dann kommst du
mit dem gesunden fuß nach vorn
am anfang hatte ich diese angst auch
aber jetzt kann ich sogar den ganzen tag
gehen wenn du mit dieser these gehen
lernst wird dein leben besser es ging
mir wie die am anfang ist es sehr
schwierig aber ich habe es gelernt
am anfang denkt man man schaffe es aber
du wirst wieder gehen können
langsam mit gottes hilfe inschallah
wie sich die patienten fühlen weiß
nadine aus eigener erfahrung
er war 18 als er mit dem auto auf eine
mine fuhr beide beine wurden ihm bis zu
den knien weggerissen
damals glaubte er sein leben sei vorbei
das ikk half ihm wieder auf die beine
im doppelten sinne er bekam prothesen
und einen job und stieg vom ungelernten
gehilfen zum direktor auf plötzlich
beide beine zu verlieren heißt dass die
hälfte des körpers auf einen schlag weg
ist mit 18 jahren
das ist sehr sehr schwierig zu
akzeptieren
und ich denke immer an die jungen männer
die mit einer doppel amputation kommen
aber mit der zeit plötzlich einen teil
des körpers zu verlieren ist sehr
schwierig ich kann es immer noch nicht
überwinden
warum kann ich nicht trennen warum kann
ich das gras nicht mit meinen füßen
sprechen warum kann ich das wasser nicht
mit meinen füßen spüren
das schmerzt mich noch immer und was
ebenfalls wehtut ich hatte keinen
einzigen feind bis heute wieso musste
ich so sinnlos meine beine verdienen
[Musik]
die metropole kinshasa ist eine wilde
zerlumpte statt
hier sind alle probleme des landes
gebündelt unterbeschäftigung krankheit
und armut in einem aussenquartier
befindet sich das größte gefängnis des
landes man kann hier sitzen 6700
gefangene ein
gebaut wurde es für 1500 mah kanal sei
die hölle sagen
menschenrechts-organisationen das
schlimmste gefängnis afrikas der
gefängnisdirektor empfängt heute ekk
delegierte die hier regelmäßig besucher
machen und ihren präsidenten peter
maurer
maurer will die zustände des
berüchtigten gefängnisses mit eigenen
augen sehen
der direktor verweist auf den
jahrelangen krieg
wissen sie unsere gefängnisse haben
probleme wegen des krieges ohne krieg
hätten wir die nicht die über belieben
solange die resozialisierung der
gefangenen nicht stattfindet und die
prozesse so langsam gehen können wir
diese probleme nicht lösen
während der präsident das gefängnis
besichtigt müssen wir draußen bleiben
keine kamera soll die katastrophalen
zustände dokumentieren
[Musik]
menschenrechtsorganisationen nennen die
probleme beim namen gewalt
unterernährung krankheiten korruption
menschenrechtsverletzungen
[Musik]
maurer spricht nicht darüber öffentlich
anprangern ist im gegensatz zu anderen
organisationen nicht sache des ikk
generisch oder probleme die die andere
sache die vertrauliche bericht hat die
zuständigen behörden und vertraulichkeit
ist eines der höchsten güter des ikk nur
so kann es sicher stellen dass es zugang
zu orten hat wo andere nicht hinkommen
[Musik]
auch hierher kommt kaum ein fremder die
bauern wollen abraham doblo die
zerstörten felder im dschungel zeigen na
super eine scheiß spinne ich habe eine
spinne verschluckte der fußmarsch dauert
stunden es ist heiß und feucht der boden
aufgeweicht vom regen
und überall lauern gefahren denkt an die
schlangen
endlich erreichen wir die reisfelder die
das ikk finanziert aber vieles ist
zerstört weil die regierung wegen den
kranbau entlaubungsmittel gesprüht hat
das problem ist sobald das geld wert ist
das ein schlechtes zeichen wenn man die
felder ansieht könnte man denken sie
sind schön mit grün aber dort wird es
schon gelb und unbrauchbar
das ist schade
dieses dorf wurde vom ki.ka im anbau von
reis und mais unterstützt sie waren sehr
motiviert diese felder zu bewirtschaften
jeder vergleich eines mit dem anderen
mit der vernichtung der pflanzen fällt
ein großer teil der ernte weg auch die
der bananen der dorfbevölkerung drohen
krankheiten und hunger
dann zeigen uns die bauern die
versteckten kuka felder ein seltener
anblick
hier nimmt der weltweiten drogenhandel
mit kokain seinen anfang
die bauern verdienen damit gerade einmal
50 franken im monat
wieso pflanzt die aq khan weil wir keine
unterstützung haben wir haben familien
wir haben nichts mehr dass wir den
kindern geben könnten locker bringt dann
will ich mir wir sind keine kriminellen
wir sind bauen wir bebauen das land mit
mais bananen reis und maniok aber so
krampen sie auf uns herum
die menschen haben keine unterstützung
und kämpfen ums überleben
sie wissen vielleicht nicht mal was mit
dem coca später geschieht
sie haben ihre felder und damit können
sie geld für niemand bietet ihnen eine
alternative
und sie müssen medikamente bezahlen
kleider das lebensnotwendige
[Musik]
abraham duplo will den bauern helfen
damit sie von der regierung
kompensationszahlungen erhalten
und er will die konfliktparteien
informieren in genf soll stéphanie lr
mit dem autor für die widrigen umstände
im feld üben willkommen hier im tc mein
name ist martin ihr kennt du zu euch zu
uns sagen 'bitte steigt ein idealer
weise hinter das steuerrad und die
männer dann eben alles okay kannst du
mich hören
der co pilot kann auf den tachometer
schauen ob wir wirklich mit 60 fahren
[Applaus]
das war großartig aber nicht vergessen
zu atmen
zum schluss gebe ich euch noch ein paar
philosophische gedanken mit solange er
mit dem fahrzeug arbeitet mit den
bremsen mit den bedingungen die ihr habt
mit eurer persönlichen form mit den
personen die hinten sitzen
werdet ihr vielleicht nie einen unfall
haben aber in dem moment wo ihr euch
gegen etwas stimmt dann habt ihr
probleme
das ist wie im leben so lange mit eurer
frau arbeitet werdet ihr keine probleme
haben wenn ihr gegen sie seit vielleicht
schon wie im wirklichen leben also einen
schönen tag
die abreise naht und stefanies aufregung
wächst
wenn ich am steuer sitze denke ich ich
fahre ein lka auto ich weiß es nicht
kaputtmachen
es ist schwierig zu beschreiben ich bin
aufgeregt wie ein fünfjähriges kind vor
weihnachten
[Applaus]
[Musik]
zurück im ikk prothesen zentrum will
kabul
hierher kommen menschen die in einem
spital nicht behandelt würden
sie erhalten kostenlos prothesen und
rollstühle männer frauen und kinder
[Musik]
direktor nacho oudin ist in der
abteilung für frauen diese erlauben uns
zu drehen das zentrale bilder den frauen
sind in der öffentlichkeit kaum zu sehen
90 prozent aller afghanen sind
analphabetinnen das ist ein erbe der
taliban
vorher war das anders versuchen sie das
knie nicht zu beugen
lassen sie es ausgestreckt sie haben mir
gesagt dass sie auf eine mine getreten
sind wo war diese mini lag sie auf der
erde
sie war vergaben im boden drin
die kleine somalia hat ein problem mit
ihren füßen was isst du
[Musik]
sie ist eng geworden und sie sitzt nicht
mehr richtig
ohne die prothesen könnten die menschen
nichts zum unterhalt der familie
beisteuern
und während außenseiter von den 300
angestellten sind fast alle ehemalige
patienten ihre erfahrung kann hier
weiterhelfen
natürlich ist es traurig behinderte zu
sehen
aber wenn sie wieder gehen können und
den weg zurück in die gesellschaft
finden dann ist das hier ein glücklicher
[Musik]
in kinshasa stehen für peter maurer
mehrere treffen an
aber wie spricht man die ehrenwerte
gesellschaft der kongolesischen
politiker an
mit präsident
nur habe dass ich der nummer 14 riesige
ställe haben die streiks los
dabei bin ich
excel auf die kraft beim premierminister
spürt man etwas vom reichtum des
rohstoffreichen landes das geld
verschwindet größtenteils in den taschen
der herrschenden klasse peter maurer
will auch über die armee sprechen die
sich teilweise menschen rechtswidrig
verhält
ein heikles thema wir müssen draußen
warten weiter zur nächsten station im
polit marathon
maurer trifft den senatspräsidenten
kenko war dumm du die nummer zwei nach
präsident joseph kabila auch hier hat
maurer handfeste interessen die
situation in den überfüllten
gefängnissen muss besser werden sagt er
er will druck machen aber auch hier gilt
dass verschwiegenheit gebot
vielen dank für ihre unterstützung
die sonne
trotz der kritik der senatspräsident ist
angetan vom ikrk
das ist eine organisation die ich
respektiere
weil es eine organisation ist die sich
um erlebte der menschen kümmert das ist
sehr wichtig
auch maurer hat gepunktet er hat auf
mich einen sehr guten eindruck gemacht
ich denke er wird das ikk in eine noch
bessere zukunft führen
maurer konnte die gefängnis misere
ansprechen aber vieles hängt vom geld ab
heute morgen fertig sind da guckt
besonders hervorzuheben und der beiden
präsidenten von nationalversammlung und
senat zeige dass situation in den
gefängnissen und eine budget
allokationen ansprechen und ich hoffe
dass das wir nach afrika bis vorhaben
in zukunft bei der exekutive besser zum
beispiel ein gerechteres justizsystem
das wolle auch die justizministerin hat
maurer
in ihr habe das ikk eine verbündete
ich habe nicht den eindruck dass das
rechtssystem oder die verwaltung im
osten korrekt funktionieren
als peter maurer ihr erzählt dass er im
eigenen flugzeug nach kuba fliegen wird
lädt sie sich zum mitfliegen 1
reisen sie mit der monusco nein mit
unserem flugzeug
[Musik]
ich will nächste woche auch dorthin
fliegen
nein wir sind neutral unparteiisch und
unabhängig also fliegen wir neutral
unparteiisch und unabhängig
dasselbe würde maurer auch präsident
joseph kabila sorgen mehr um ein
gespräch mit dem staatsminister ad weil
die schwierig stecken sprach man die
größten differenzen und nachher geht's
wieder situationen wie jetzt da hier wo
man gespürt dass die justizministerin
eigentlich die einstellung von michael
kraus und dasselbe regens luxury
vitalwelt den vor den anleger von nico
ukrainer hat vom politischen system wird
stéphanie lr ist gestresst
sie hat den ersten teil der 6 monatigen
ausbildung zu delegierten abgeschlossen
morgen fliegt sie zu ihrem einsatzort
alles dreht sich alles dreht und ich
denke ich muss das machen und das machen
aber eigentlich müsste ich mich ein
wenig entspannen
das meer aber ich kann nicht aufhören
gedanken zu machen
ich kann mich gut austoben im entspannen
bin ich nicht so gut
ich war mental auf bagdad jenen oder
afghanistan vorbereitet aber als man mir
gesagt hat
tel aviv war meine erste reaktion ich
fand dass ich möchte nichts sagen aber
ich hätte mir als erste mission etwas
extremeres vorgestellt aber jetzt sage
ich mir
krk delegierter war schon lange
stefanies traumjob darum hat sie in genf
internationale beziehungen studiert und
dann verschiedene praktika im ausland
gemacht aber auf etwas ist sie jetzt
ganz besonders stolz
den hat mir nicht fürs training
ganz allein
das sind meine rechte niedriger papiere
[Musik]
und das sehen sie in der nächsten folge
newcomerin stephanie lr nimmt in israel
ihre arbeit auf und hat ihr erstes
erfolgserlebnis als delegierte abraham
doblo will mit rebellen verhandeln und
begibt sich in gefahr
[Musik]
nadine verhilft einem patienten zu einer
neuen prothese und einem neuen leben
[Musik]
und präsident peter maurer ist
erschüttert vom schicksal der
kriegswaisen in goma
[Musik]